okay another white game play d4 okay
well let's take the chance to to play a
French last time I played 93 yeah I got
them I got some difficulties with a rare
line so on I try to play tirage now here
to maybe get a somewhat similar position
it's a easier to play position yeah
you're okay a plane we should be seven
Black has some quite a lot of options
here between be six or some less
aggressive options there should be seven
intends to play quitting f6 I think f6
now or f5 this is also possible to
completely block the position
one positive point is that I actually
managed to castle this is not a given in
this line here what I think why should
have a comfortable position here Queen B
6 or some also yeah it's a standard move
but how does he untangle its pieces here
ok and this sun and this looks weird to
me actually need to calculate bishop h7
let's take at my table h7 King takes now
g5 check Bishop takes rook takes f7 this
is some this is a possibility already
mm-hmm most likely it is also good for
white but maybe maybe I am widowed gay
he's maybe intending night f8 and then I
don't have any possibilities to two sec
them and that's not one hundred percent
clear but the car let's go for this
sorry
problem is that the CHP shaban the rukon
e8 are basically dead and it's not so
easy to get them into play quickly right
now g5 is also hanging so I need to
address this and if it takes on c1 I
have my routine play immediately rook C
1 C 3 and so on this is the debris point
of the sacrifice slaps I'm not a
material gain and now also maybe just
threaten Queen d3 here quindi three ok
is some attacking the rook yeah okay but
let's say yeah I can just retreat to f3
now I'm threatening rook g3 pinning the
bishop and he's only got the
alternatives of taking which is terrible
I just recapture and then threat not so
night f4 yeah this is just winning i
think i'm not sure yeah okay route g3
end and that's it
yeah this was an opening disaster from
like yeah I don't think the some kind of
setup with if you play f68 you need to
play far more aggressively and really
try to break up the center this was um
was quite comfortable for me also queen
bee 6057 this was I was just bad lost
too much time there maybe if he if he
doesn't play Queen B 6 but maybe play
play rook f7 there and then 9 f8 but
white is better anyway was a space
advantage he doesn't lose ok I'll do a
capture I guess taking this tempo
shouldn't hurt
yeah well another 10 / cannot go Queen
g6 because of root page 3 now what about
g7 we should have six or bishop age 6
yeah this is some reasonable
quite sure why why is continuing
actually black bruise on ok yeah I guess
some random main the main move in this
pollution is Queen B 6 and maybe this is
all so yeah just the best move trying to
get immediate treasure here on the
center um not quite sure here I don't
know that theory I'm really well so but
i'm pretty sure that this kind of
structure should be you should be
somewhat better for white ok this is
maybe just losing a comp comp doesn't
want to take interesting oh i thought
this would be it would be a huge
advantage King g8 he's giving us the
best defense yeah but now it's yeah with
some time it's it's going to allow it
once for white yeah yeah should be this
is just too too quick quick on the king
and the rukon daa then the bishop are
just too tangled up ok quick win and
ready for next game